OK.
So it wasn't just Kamala Harris who had a
great interview this weekend, which which
we looked at already.
Joe Biden did an event in Delaware about rebuilding
the American economy, about rebuilding the
country really once Donald Trump is gone.
And so, first of all, there are Trump people
who say Biden won't leave the basement as
they like to say.
Biden did an event.
He's not scared to speak.
He spoke perfect, perfectly fine.
Seemed far sharper than Donald Trump.
Biden also took media questions again.
The Trump people say Biden won't do it.
Biden would crumble under questioning.
Biden doesn't know where he is.
He can't put together a sentence.
Didn't go that way.
And Joe Biden was asked about that Trump conspiracy
group.
I'm not even going to name it because YouTube
instantly demagnetize.
If you mentioned that group, YouTube instantly
democratizes it.
But let me put it this way.
It's related to the letter that comes after
P in the alphabet.
Let's just leave it there, if I'm sure you
know what I mean.
And Biden is asked about that and Biden just
destroys it and goes very hard and says people
need mental health services.
Now, Biden is right about that.
This is a crazy group with outrageous beliefs
or claims.
But some of the people that subscribe to those
views might get elected in November, as Alex
Kaplan from Media Matters told us last week,
which is disturbing to recognize.
Check out Joe Biden's response of the Q and
on the people who believe in that conspiracy.
What they think is true about America is that
there's sex trafficking and conspiracy against
then President Trump.
And what would you say to President Trump
for not rejecting that conspiracy and the
people who believe in it?
I've been a big supporter of mental health.
I'd recommend that people believe it, maybe
you should take advantage while it still exists
in the Affordable Care Act.
It's bizarre, totally bizarre.
And now have you guys found that plane load
of people in uniforms and weapons and flying
around?
I mean, you have you found him yet?
Does anybody even from by the way, I respect
conservative and liberal points of view in
the press.
Anybody found that plane?
What in God's name are we doing?
Look at how it makes us look around the world.
It's mortify.
It's embarrassing.
It it's dangerous.
It's dangerous.
The president doesn't know better, which I
mean, he has to know to my lord.
Much more trouble than I thought we were.
What in God's name are we doing is sort of,
in my mind, the slogan for the last four years.
It's a relevant phrase, not just when it comes
to this group, but it's a relevant phrase,
big picture for the administration.
Joe Biden very clearly saying what many of
us, what many in my audience have been thinking,
which is how does the entire country not realize
what the world realizes, which is that we
are a laughing stock with Donald Trump in
the White House.
We have become a joke.
Joe Biden saying it.
And then Joe Biden again showing more energy
this weekend than we've seen from him in a
while because he was very fired up about the
story that Donald Trump said troops who died
in combat are losers and suckers.
Biden visibly furious and disgusted with Donald
Trump.
This is a couple of minutes almost, but I
want to show you the entire answer, quite
frankly, if it is written and it is true,
is disgusting.
In affirms what most of us believe to be true.
Donald Trump is not fit to do the job of president,
be the commander in chief.
President reportedly said, and I emphasize
reportedly said that those who sign up to
serve instead of doing something more lucrative
are suckers.
Let me be real clear.
When my son was an assistant U.S. attorney
and he volunteered to go to Kosovo.
The war is going on as a civilian.
You want to sucker?
When my son volunteered.
And join the United States military as the
attorney general went to Iraq for a year,
won the Bronze Star and other commendations.
He wasn't a sucker.
The service men and women he served with.
Particularly those did not come home.
We're not losers.
These statements are true.
The president should humbly apologize.
Jeffrey, Gold Star, mother and father, Navy
Blue Star family that he's denigrated and
insulted.
Who the heck does he think he is?
If it's true and based on all the things you
said, I believe the article is true, I'd ask
you all the rhetorical question, how do you
feel?
How would you feel if you had a kid in Afghanistan?
How would you feel?
If lost her son, daughter, husband, wife.
This was also really instructive, too, from
the standpoint of what I call Didi s Democratic
derangement syndrome.
You simultaneously had Republicans criticizing
that answer for diametrically opposed reasons.
You had some Republicans saying, oh, my goodness,
Joe Biden's unhinged.
He's going crazy about fake news.
And then you had other Republicans who, because
the story has been quadruply corroborated,
believe the story saying what's wrong with
Biden?
Biden should have been more mad.
It almost seems like he was of low energy.
He could barely even really gets that.
That's weird.
Why wasn't Biden more furious about the comment?
If he believes that he is it?
Does he not support the troops?
So if you take every side of an issue, as
Donald Trump and Trump is typically do.
You've got this sort of something for everybody
framing, which I've mentioned for some time.
Remember, Joe Biden said right before Super
Tuesday, we have to beat Trump and the Republicans,
but we can't become like them.
And I think that in our criticism of Donald
Trump about this suckers and losers thing,
in our continued exploration of Donald Trump's
denial of strokes that nobody actually accused
him of having in all of this, we have to make
sure that we don't become like them.
I tend to agree with Joe Biden.
I want to win.
But if we win the way they win, have we really
won?
And I've talked about this before.
And I think it's something to keep in mind,
especially as we get closer to the debates,
which I'll be talking about next.
Just imagine if we see a fired up Joe Biden
at the debates.
I don't think it will come off as unhinged.
I think it will come off as genuine.
And it will actually reflect the feelings
of many in this country, including some of
us who know that when every week is a scandal,
you start to become a little desensitized.
So I was glad to see this.
I think we're going to see more of it.
Make sure you're following us on Instagram
at David Pakman show while you're there.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.
You can see some of my recent prepping elements
that I've purchased.
Quick break.
Back after this.
The
David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.